Utah's domain expansion finally revealed
as we learned a secret plan to take down
sukuna once and for all the king of
curses wants to kill everyone and force
Humanity to merge with Tangen but first
he has to fight Utah ra and Yuji inside
of Utah's insane domain so let's talk
about it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy my jjk videos you want to see more
in the future drop a quick like and
comment for that YouTube algorithm and
real talk now we are only like 2,000
subscribers away from 2 million so do me
a huge TR guys subscribe right now the
previous chapter gave us the aftermath
of the battle between higuma and Yuji
versus sukuna for like one10 of a second
back in chapter 247 it looked like
sukuna might actually be in trouble as
it seemed like Yuji might be able to
stab him with the Executioner sword and
higuma literally like sacrificed his
life to make this happen but then as
soon as chapter 248 started we saw that
the attempt to stab sukuna was
ineffective the Executioner sword simply
kind of like shrunk and dissolved in you
IU's hand moments after higuma
apparently died the only consolation
seemed to be that sukuna lost his prized
cursed object and that for some reason
Kirara and UI were going through the
trouble of collecting everyone's bodies
from the battlefield and taking them
back to shoko this includes the body of
higuma and also the body of Gojo himself
this kind of gave us hope that maybe the
sorcerers have some kind of plan to
bring even severely injured Fighters
like Gojo back to life there's no
indication of how they might be able to
do this exact L but when you're a
hardcore Gojo coper like me even the
smallest breadcrumb matters in the last
chapter we also learned that Yuji
already managed to master reverse curse
technique which is how he was able to
heal himself after suffering a massive
injury earlier on a new rule was then
suddenly added to the culling game which
stated that megumi fushiguro has the
authority to activate the merger between
humanity and master Tang It And since
sukuna is currently occupying megumi's
body this means that sukuna is the one
with this Authority now initially the
sorcerers thought that kaku's dream of
merging Humanity with Tangen in order to
force the evolution of humanity was
something that wouldn't interest sukuna
but unfortunately sukuna confirmed that
yes he also wants to do this sukuna
plans to kill everyone in the calling
game activate the merger with Tangen and
then initiate the evolution of humanity
his motivations for this are not the
same as Kaku he doesn't care about jiutu
experiments and the evolution of
humanity but he does wonder if the
entity that emerges from the merger of
humanity with tangan could prove to be a
worthy opponent for him and so sukuna
who doesn't care one bit about other
people and sees them as only a source of
entertainment thinks it might be fun to
see if the evolution of humanity might
actually give him a truly worthy
opponent for the first time in over
1,000 years the last chapter ended with
UT arriving to the battlefield and using
Raa the queen of curses to attack sukuna
the king of curses the new chapter
starts off with a little flashback to
the moment right after Utah relieved
Kaku of his head with kenju no longer
control of ghetto body all the cursed
spirits that the ghetto body had stored
within itself suddenly poured out and
went on a rampage and UTA had to summon
R in order to deal with them while UT
and ra were dealing with the Stampede of
cursed Spirits Kaku head was able to
create the new rule about megumi being
able to initiate the merger between
Tangen and Humanity we see that Tangen
is now just a tiny caterpillar esque
cakon Tangen has been readed for the
merger and the cakon was then sent
flying all the way to sukuna sukuna then
grabbed the cakon and devoured it this
is that light that we saw sukuna
grabbing and seemingly eating back in
the last chapter but even though sukuna
now has the power to activate the
merging ritual we know that he is
planning to kill all the players in the
calling game first it seems like we
probably won't have to worry about the
merger happening anytime soon since
sukuna isn't planning to willingly
initiate it until he's completed his
business by killing everyone in the
culling game this means that there is
still time to stop sukuna and save the
world if only someone can figure out a
way to do it after the new rule is added
UTA hunts down kaku's head and impales
it upon his Katana however Kaku isn't
too troubled by his own defeat and death
he's glad that he got to have some fun
with takaba and of course he is glad
that sukuna will become the successor of
his will and so kaku's death seems to be
confirmed now but unfortunately his
master plan lives on I still can't
believe that Kaku is seemingly dead and
yet we still didn't learn why he decided
to become IU 's mother but it is what it
is back in the present UTA notices that
sua's reverse curse technique output is
starting to recover and it's only
logical to conclude that he will
probably also be able to use his domain
expansion again very soon to make things
worse higuma has been taken out by
sukuna and UTA feels guilty because he
couldn't stay on the battlefield and
help if he had stayed then it's possible
that heguru must plan to pierce sukuna
with the Executioner sword could have
worked but UTA couldn't stay because he
had to be be the one to defeat kenju
because only Rika could deal with the
Avalanche of cursed spirits that were
released from gto's body upon kaku's
death UTA then launches a frontal
assault on sukunai using both Raa and
his sword but sukunai is able to dodge
and avoid Serious injury however as the
two-on-one battle continues UTA does
manage to land some blows on sukuna
including a powerful punch to sukuna gut
where that second mouth of his is
located Utah is definitely holding his
own in battle but at the same time he's
not really making any major inroads
sukuna is still standing strong and the
longer Utah waits to end the battle the
longer sukuna will have to recover his
cursed energy levels and initiate his
domain expansion time is on sukuna side
not uta's so UTA has to act right now
UTA then accepts the responsibility for
what happened to higuma because he did
want to be the one to finish Kaku off
with his own hands he Bears
responsibility for hig's death and so he
must be the one to finish this and he
will finish it by revealing his domain
expansion as a shocked sukuna looks on
Utah and sukuna find themselves inside
what looks like a brutal medieval
Samurai training ground the domain is
full of katanas that are sticking out of
half broken cross-shaped pillars that
are presumably used for some kind of
combat training the official name of
uta's domain will be confirmed once we
get the official translations but the
initial translations give the name as
true love which I think is an extremely
fitting name for uta's domain given his
backstory with Ara sukuna knows that
this domain is no joke and so he uses
Hollow wicker basket to protect himself
from the guaranteed hit effect of uta's
true love as you might recall Hollow
wicker basket is an ancient anti-d
domain technique that is a sort of
predecessor to simple domain and in the
past we've seen reggi star and hajim
mosimo using this same technique but
just because sukuna is protecting
himself from the guaranteed hit of uta's
domain doesn't mean he is safe from Utah
altogether and so UT launches another
attack on the king of curses UTA uses
one of the swords inside his domain to
attack with thin ice breaker the
technique he copied from takako uro at
first it looks like sukuna didn't suffer
that much damage but after the technique
takes its full toll sukuna realizes that
he actually suffered some real damage to
his face after this attack UTA sword
seems to like shatter and disappear as
if it was used up which makes me wonder
whether every single one of the dozens
of Swords inside the domain might
contain the ability to use one of the
techniques that UTA has copied in the
past maybe he can only use each
technique once and then the sword
disappears at least until next time he
opens his domain expansion now that
would be a pretty great feature of uta's
domain he just keeps grabbing different
swords and sukuna has no idea with which
technique he's going to be hit next
sukuna quickly realizes what the
strategy to defeat him actually is he
knows that UTA has the power to copy the
techniques of others and he knows that
the guaranteed hit of the domain is
forcing sukuna to continue using Hollow
wicker basket which means that he has to
use half of his arms and mouths to
perform that technique and can't use
them for other things so UTA will
continue to attack sukuna with different
swords and different techniques which
will keep the rest of his arms busy
while the main strategy will actually be
to attack sukuna Soul because guess who
else is currently inside of this domain
that's right Yuji itadori the sorcerer
who has the ability to grab the soul of
his opponent and attack it directly the
plan of the sorcerers is to use Yuji to
detach sukuna soul from megumi's body
and then to destroy sukuna without
hurting megumi sukuna now understands
that Yuji also has an important role to
play in this fight it's not just Utah
and ra versus sukuna it's UTA Raa and
Yuji versus the king of curses and it's
all happening on Utah's home turf inside
his domain this is absolutely epic we
finally see uta's domain expansion Yuji
is finally assuming an important role in
the battle after spending so much time
on the sidelines and what makes this
turn of events even better is the fact
that we now know that sukuna is
personally bothered By Yuji as we
learned in the last chapter he is kind
of jealous of Yuji and his unbreakable
ideals something that sukunai himself
never had and never needed to have and
so this fight will actually be personal
for sukuna normally fights are never
personal to him he never takes it as
anything more than entertainment but
this time it's different because of Yuji
and how well sukuna got to know Yuji
while sharing the same body but even
though the sorcerers now seem to have a
good plan and even though even sukuna
seems kind of worried I still think that
this is kind of too good to be true
every time it looks like sukuna might be
at a disadvantage gig smashes our hopes
to Pieces as sukuna ends up turning the
tables on the sorcerers again and again
I feel like something else has to happen
to really ensure that the heroes can
actually win something like Maki
entering the domain and making it a 4v1
or UTA somehow managing to recreate the
Executioner sword within his domain or
my boy Gojo coming back to life yeah
baby Gojo copers forever speaking of
Gojo check out my video on the biggest
controversy in jiujitsu Kaizen the big
Gojo drama that divided the fandom link
on screen and in the description if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like to
let me know and we are only like 2,000
subscribers away from hitting 2 million
do me a huge favor and subscribe right
now